the wealthy generally mastered these
three steps to becoming financially free
and here's what it is Step number one
they choose one skill one skill and they
Master it which means they have to
constantly be working on this to become
one of the best at this one skill step
number two they choose one industry and
they stick to this industry for 10 years
one industry and they stay in it for 10
years number three they find ways how to
be at 50 100 200 a thousand different
places at the same time you may say Pat
how do they do that it's called Leverage
they Master leverage through people they
Master leverage through technology they
Master leverage through resources they
Master leverage through media so they
take their skill set that they mastered
they stay in the one industry and they
learn about leverage and how they can be
in many different places at the same
time and all of a sudden they create
wealth